hey I didn't do much I didn't study much
language Persian or whatever I did a
little bit uh but I had some work to do
this morning I went shopping with my
wife we had some golf balls on the
driving range
I came back and I had to activate my
bank card and I had to wait for an hour
and so I didn't get much done and now
I'm about to watch my favorite hockey
team the Vancouver Canucks
on my computer
so not so much uh person learning but
I'm not concerned plus my tutor
in Iran Sarah she found me a PDF an
e-book and of course I can import that
ebook ebook into link it like took no
time at all it's like a few seconds bam
I've got this ebook
that I can go through sentence by
sentence so I got that to look forward
to so didn't get much done it doesn't
matter you gotta enjoy all the things
you do including learning languages so
talk to you later